le 19 novembre 1863 à prat minime
qu'elle prononce le discours de
gettysburg qui restera dans les mémoires
et qui demeure encore aujourd'hui un
symbole important pour bon nombre
d'américains
au cours de ce discours abraham indom
dira que la démocratie est le
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple
pour le peuple et la démocratie c'est
quoi
[Musique]
oui
cette définition pose certains problèmes
roberto michels 11 la loi d'airain de
l'oligarchie
cette loi dit en fait que toute
collectivité toute organisation humaine
un certain moment va conduire à
l'instauration d'une oligarchie donc un
ensemble de personnes les minorités qui
vont finalement dirigé dominer une
majorité robert michels dit simplement
qu'une minorité dirigeante va exercer
c'est un certain pouvoir sur une
majorité dirigés vue de cette façon la
démocratie posent problème parce que
finalement très peu de systèmes peuvent
être alors qualifié de parfaitement
démocratique
il nous faut sortir de cette impasse
intellectuelle en instaurant une autre
définition qui nous permettra de
caractériser ce qu'est le système
politique que l'on appelle la démocratie
c'est ce que propose cette vidéo un
système politique qui se voudrait
démocratique devrait respecter trois
règles
tout d'abord le choix des dirigeants
ensuite la séparation et le contrôle des
différents pouvoirs et enfin le respect
des libertés individuelles
dans une démocratie le peuple doit donc
pouvoir choisir librement ses dirigeants
on pense évidemment à l'élection qui est
devenu finalement le symbole même de la
démocratie et beaucoup de personnes dans
les conversations de tous les jours mais
aussi sur le discours de différents
experts ou soi-disant experts vont nous
dire que la démocratie c'est l'élection
or l'élection n'est qu'une modalité pour
choisir des dirigeants on peut tout à
fait penser que le tirage au sort parmi
les citoyens d'une population composée
une population pourrait être un élément
qui permettrait de choisir et dirigeant
de manière démocratique
également en démocratie il doit bien y
avoir une séparation des pouvoirs alors
les pouvoirs généralement
que l'on définit son le pouvoir
législatif qui fait les lois le pouvoir
exécutif qui exécute ses lois et le
pouvoir judiciaire qui va trancher les
litiges et qui va reste faire respecter
les lois
chacun de ces pouvoirs finalement on va
avoir une influence sur l'autre et va
avoir un certain contrôle la
constitution américaine et
particulièrement bien fait de ce point
de vue où le président américain
le pouvoir exécutif finalement n'a pas
tous les pouvoirs et doit rendre des
comptes à la fois au congrès le pouvoir
législatif mais aussi à la cour suprême
c'est à dire le pouvoir judiciaire il ya
vraiment un équilibre à trouver pour
qu'on puisse considérer un système comme
démocratique
il ne faut pas non plus faire l'impasse
sur les différents contre pouvoirs qui
peuvent exister dans une démocratie on
pense bien sûr à une presse libre mais
aussi à des mouvements syndicaux des
mouvements associatifs des mouvements
citoyens des ong par exemple qui
pourrait elle aussi exercer un certain
contrôle ou en tout cas une certaine
critique sur l'exercice du pouvoir
enfin dans un système démocratique on
doit considérer que les individus qui
composent le peuple chaque individu a
des droits inaliénables qu'on ne peut
lui retirer ces fameux droits de l'homme
qui ont été énoncées dans différents
contextes et qu'on va retrouver dans les
différentes constitutions des états
démocratiques modernes
bien sûr ces droits doivent être
garantis et ils peuvent être garanties
par l'état de droit d'ailleurs c'est le
seul type d'état qui peut garantir ses
libertés individuelles donc l'état de
droit c'est le fait de respecter les
lois de ne pas faire deux poids deux
mesures et que finalement chaque
individu chaque citoyen est protégé par
cette étape droit qui va empêcher toute
mesure arbitraire qui pourrait
nuire aux libertés individuelles de
chacun lio brève mais intense touche à
sa fin je vous propose éventuellement
d'autres vidéos ici qui peuvent vous
aider à mieux comprendre finalement le
monde dans lequel on vit
vous pouvez toujours vous abonner à la
chaîne la société ecc
vous vous retrouverez d'autres vidéos
sur les sciences politiques et sociales
mais aussi quelques vidéos sur la
géographie
n'oubliez pas les commentaires j'y
répondrai le plus rapidement possible si
vous avez des commentaires à faire des
questions à poser ou des rectifications
proposées sur cette vidéo je vous
souhaite une très bonne fin de soirée
c'est selon mon travail et à travers
tous
[Musique]